باسميها المراكز الحضاريه
الحقيقه في الجزيره العربيه كثيره جدا
ومتعدده يعني اذا اخذنا مثلا معظم مدن
وعواصم جنوب الجزيره العربيه همم ثم نعرج
الى منطقه نجران ثم ندخل الى وسط الجزء
العربي نجد الفاو ونجد الافلاج والخارج في
وسط الجزء العربيه ثم ننتقل الى همم الى
الشمال الى همم وهي عديده جدا همم منطقه
جبه في حائل المنطقه ادماته اللي هاد هجوم
دومه الجندل تيما همم
والعلا وديدان في غرب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وذلك في شرقها نجد ايضا همم ساج وغيرها من
المواقع اللي تعود الى الفتره العبيد الى
الفتره دلما اول حتى الفترات الاسلاميه
فهي متعدده كثير جدا كما قلنا وكان نقول
دائما الجزيره العربيه هي فسيفساء في
جغرافيهتها وفي بيئتها وفي ثقافتها وفي
عاداتها وفي تقاليدها هذه الفسيفساء يجب
ان تظهر على السطح ويجب ان يعرف لسانها
بانه يفترض به ان يستفيد ويستغل هذه
الامكانيات لان يتحجر في فكر معين او في
منهج معين او في القبيل ويتناسى بان
اجداده كان لهم دور كبير حتى الفتره
الاسلاميه عندما خرج ااا خرجت الجحافر
الجيوش من هذه المنطقه من هذه الجزيره
انتقلوا الى جميع انحاء العالم ناشرين هذا
الدين الاسلامي منها الجزيره هذه التي
انبثقت دكتور
الحضارات الخارجيه هل نضرب امثله محدده ما
هي ابرز الحضارات الخارجيه اللي كانت على
اتصال مع الجزيره العربيه اما بسبب
التجاره او بسبب السياسه او بسبب الثقافه
والدينا احيانا الحقيقه الحضارات المحيطه
كلها كل الجزيره العربيه احتكا ثقافيه
وتجاريا وحضاريا مع الحضارات الموجوده في
همم بلاد الرافدين مع الحضره الموجوده في
سوريا الكبرى سوريا الكبرى اللي هي من
سوريا الحاليه الى لبنان مع الحضارات في
مصر فرعونيه قديم الفرعونيه ايضا مع
الحضارات التلت تلك الحضارات حتى وصلت الى
الحضاره الرومانيه الى ما هي قبيله
الاسلام وبعد قبيل الميلاد ثم بعد الميلاد
ايضا احتك بها العرب واستفادوا منها
الفتره المظلمه الحقيقه في الجزيره
العربيه هي تعود الى القرن القرن الثاني
او حنقول لقرن الرابع تقريبا الرابع الى
سابع ميلادي هذه اللي عانت فيه الجزء
العربيه لانه لم يكن فيها حكم سياسي ثابت
بعد سقطت المملكه النبطيه وهي
بقليل هذه الفتره التي
يفسر انه سرعه انتشار الاسلام
الدين الاسلامي الذي الله سبحانه وتعالى
فضل مكه المكرمه